[Musique]
bonjour premier numéro de bienvenue en
yvelines le magazine qui vous fera
découvrir le patrimoine les richesses
des communes du département au cours de
chacune des émissions nous ferons escale
dans des villes très différentes qui ont
su évoluer pour répondre aux besoins des
habitants tout en valorisant à leurs
racines
aujourd'hui nous sommes à maurepas un
village agricole jusque dans les années
60 sous l'urbanisation s'est faite de
manière très rapide en même temps que
l'arrivée le développement de la ville
nouvelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en
1975 maurepas comptait quelques 14 mille
habitants contre seulement 1807 an
auparavant et pour débuter ce numéro
nous sommes à l'église saint-sauveur
l'un des plus vieux bâtiments de cette
commune de morphine
[Musique]
bonjour clergue et organisé vous êtes
architecte du patrimoine et vous avez
mené une étude sur cette église
saint-sauveur qui est situé donc sur la
ville de de maurepas et on va en parler
un petit peu avec vous tout d'abord les
grandes lignes les raisons de cette
étude que vous avez pu mener c'est une
étude préalable à la restauration de
l'église qui a été commandée par la
ville de maurepas c'est une église qui
existait déjà au moyen-âge il est comme
toutes les églises elle a subi pas mal
de fils de vicissitudes de démolition de
reconstruction elle été modifiée à
toutes les époques
alors les vestiges médiévaux il n'en
reste pas beaucoup ce qui reste on les
voit ici sur la façade occidentale de
l'église avec une ancienne porte en art
brisées et des vestiges de l'enceinte
villageoise par contre l'essentiel de
l'église telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est le 18ème siècle d agrandissement
des démolitions des modifications qui
date de l'époque des faits l'ipo de
pontchartrain
quand il était content de maurepas et
puis en 1975 il ya eu de nouveau une
grande transformation de l'église et
les terres actuelles résultent de ces
derniers travaux de 75 sur
l'implantation même de cette église
pourquoi se trouve-t-elle à cet endroit
là précisément il y avait des
fortifications autour qui s'étendait
beaucoup plus loin que la ville de
maurepas on est sur un site sur une
position stratégique au moyen-âge dès le
haut moyen âge une position en hauteur
pour surveiller la plaine de neauphle
qui a été un couloir d'invasion de
l'ile-de-france par les vikings puis les
anglais
donc il ya tout un réseau de
fortifications sur les coteaux qui
entoure cette pleine d'amour pas fait
partie qu'est ce qui en fait un monument
ou pas peut-être remarquable on alors
c'est l'ensemble on peut pas dissocier
l'église saint sauveur de ce site ce
site avec sa position stratégique en
rapport avec les autres forteresses et
les autres villages qui sont sur les
coteaux autour de la plaine en rapport
avec la forteresse et avec le donjon
ruiner c'est tout cet ensemble castrale
du moyen-âge qui est très très grand
très grand intérêt historique
architectural patrimonial et
archéologiques
il existe dans n'est qu'un élément il
faut la comprendre dans cet ensemble
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes maintenant à l'intérieur de
cette église saint-sauveur à maurepas on
retrouve déjà pour commencer le 7 ces
deux héritages 12e et 18e siècles sur la
construction
il ya beaucoup d'époque et beaucoup
d'héritage et des époques intermédiaire
je me disais tout à l'heure le village a
été détruit pendant la guerre de cent
ans et donc l'église a été reconstruite
il ya donc pas mal d'ouvragés qui date
de la fin du xvème siècle et du 16e
siècle comme les voûtes gothiques
on va dire un mélange de vestiges
médiévaux comme ici ce pilier rond ces
arcs césar brisé des parties médiévale
comme les voûtes d'ogives et puis des
vestiges aussi du xviiie par exemple ce
mobilier qui est décomposé aujourd'hui
mais qui date de l'époque des faits
l'ipo de pontchartrain qu'on ne demande
pas au xviiie siècle
c'est un un décor de menuiserie très
riche qui ornait tout le coeur et qui a
été des structures et en 1975 il en
reste seulement des éléments qui ont été
restaurées isolément et qui sont
présentés tout seul sur les murs je
pense que les habitants ils sont très
attachés à cette église et c'est
l'origine même du village c'est l'âme du
village le village s'est développé
autour et elle est en dialogue avec la
forteresse à côté qui un jour ou l'autre
elle aussi sera étudiée mise en valeur
parce que c'est ensemble un très très
grand intérêt patrimonial et historique
à l'échelle de l'île de france
merci beaucoup de nous avoir éclairé sur
cette église saint-sauveur de maurepas
et puis quand à nous l'émission va se
poursuivre on va quitter ce centre de
maurepas village on va se diriger à
quelques kilomètres de là vers le centre
ville cette fois ci à son origine se
trouve dans les années 60 et il est
l'oeuvre d'un urbaniste jacquerie bout
de quelques centaines à plusieurs
milliers d'habitants la construction de
la ville de maurepas a été fulgurante
elle débute officiellement en 1966 et
jacques figue ou urbanistes reconnu est
choisi pour façonner la nouvelle commune
l'ancien entrepreneur pétrolier s'est
fait un nom depuis la construction
harmonieuse de la ville voisine de
villepreux dont il ait eu la charge
quelques années auparavant son duo formé
avec l'architecte roland prédire y
impose à l'époque une nouvelle vision de
l'urbanisme à contre-courant des grands
ensembles et des tests de le corbusier
les deux hommes défendent un modèle plus
humain avec des maisons individuelles et
des bâtiments de quelques étages
une approche provincial plus attirante
pour les habitants je faisais des choses
qu'on avait déjà fait en france et qu'on
ne faisait plus qui était la cité jardin
en simplifiant cette étude un urbanisme
d'une densité de 20 à 30 habitants
l'hectare qui permet qui permet beaucoup
de maisons de forme individuelle de
forme individuelle et qui a su cela
permet beaucoup de petits jardins et en
même temps il faut prévoir des espaces
verts plus plus coordonnées mais les
gens veulent être maîtres du ch elle
même s'il est petit et du ciel c'est à
dire que je n'ai pas tenu tenu
ils sont pas tenus de demander ou
voisins si votre chien du show sur le
toit
la ville heureuse comme l'a théorisé
jacques riboud sera bâti en quelques
années seulement et à la demande de
l'urbaniste de nombreux équipements
publics sont également construit à la
même époque j'avais un problème et de
l'ouvrier l'avait très bien joué j'avais
un problème je ne pouvais pas attirer
les habitants
s'il n'y avait pas tout ce qu'il fallait
et le système ancien c'est que
l'administration publique ne crait ce
que ce qu'on a besoin c'est lorsque le
besoin s'est manifesté bon bah les
écoles on avait droit de voir des écoles
quand on avait un sermon d'enfants mais
pour attirer les gens fallait bien je
crée des écoles avant que les enfants
aillent vécue par an dans les années 70
c'est au tour de la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'être édifié
son premier coeur historique le quartier
17 mars située à elancourt se trouve
alors à quelques centaines de mètres de
la mairie de maurepas certains
affirmeront que maurepas fut un exemple
pour saint quentin en yvelines
on a été là la ville moteur en fait
sûrement repas après villepreux donc qui
faisait pas partie de la ville nouvelle
à l'époque en fait mon repas a été une
des premières villes et après d'autres
villes sont été construite au fur et à
mesure en fait on a été moteur parce
qu'on était en avait aussi la gare sncf
de la verrière était tout près des
styles architecturaux finalement très
différents entre saint quentin en
yvelines aimant passeront par la suite
le symbole d'une histoire tumultueuse
entre les deux collectivités
maurepas quittent la ville nouvelle en
1983 elle n'y retournent qu'en 2016 un
demi siècle tout juste après sa
construction
à chaque commune south et personnalités
à mort par un nom résonne encore celui
d'eric von stroheim acteur réalisateur
autrichien décédé en 1958 et qui repose
aujourd'hui dans les cimetières situé en
contrebas au côté de son épouse et erich
von stroheim un nom qui ne parlent pas
forcément aux plus jeunes et pourtant il
est considéré comme l'un des plus grands
de son époque comme charlie chaplin il
aura tourné notamment avec jean renoir
ou encore l sacha guitry rencontre à
présent avec une autre personnalité de
cette commune gérard ramond et les
sculpteurs et ses oeuvres se trouvent
sur une grande partie de cette commune
nous sommes à présent dans l'atelier du
sculpteur gérard amon nos pas à maurepas
mai à paris qui nous accueille donc ici
gérard amon bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir dans votre atelier
parisien vous avez avec jacques riboud
dont on nous avons parlé un petit peu
plus tôt au cours de cette émission est
réalisée de nombreuses sculptures
aménagements sur cette ville de maurepas
comment ou tout simplement déjà vous
êtes arrivé sur ce projet vous étiez
alors tout jeune sculpteur sortie des
beaux-arts envahi sortie des beaux-arts
tout jeune dans un petit champ sur un
petit chantier je fais la connaissance
de monsieur rioux jacques rey books
était un personnage impressionnant un
peu qui était un grand industriel déjà
du pétrole et on a sympathisé jeu pour
aider et il était très intéressé de voir
qu'avec que juste elle élève des
beaux-arts et que j'allais faire la
sculpture
pour lui c'était quelque chose de
d'inattendu et c'est là où jacques
riboud m'a proposé d'intégrer dans son
équipe
et là c'était vraiment très très nouveau
siv est exceptionnel quoique un jeune
sculpteur rentrer dans l'objectif de
constructeurs et l'idée ce que vous me
disiez un peu avant qu'on débute
l'enregistrement c'était aussi de créer
un passé dans ces villes nouvelles en
fait c'est ça le concept et le concept
de ribou andorre son côté je veux dire
curieux et et il y a eu l'idée géniale
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée
eliane il y disait on construit des
quartiers neufs
il faut de leur donner une vie immédiate
il faut pas qu'il faut que les gens sous
retrouvent sur leur passé quelque part
et lui il avait l'habitude de dire moi
je dis je parlais des sculptures et lui
parlait des statuts et j'ai compris
pourquoi il disait statut parce que ce
statut c'était plutôt l'esprit et est
justement prend dans les villes il ya
toujours une statue quelque part on dans
deux rendez-vous quand on est jeune à sa
petite amie où on fait du vélo autour
d'elle et la maman amène saison bon il
ya toujours la statue le rendez-vous est
l'huile à l'idée dans son idée il
voulait mettre des statues
vous avez une carte blanche sur la
réalisation alors vraiment a eu carte
blanche sur les matériaux je serai pas
oublié tes fait leur fallait bien
entendu que je m'intègre là ce problème
parce que bien sûr je serais venu afin
en train de faire des recherches
esthétiques contemporaines
je ne sais pas si j'aurai plus non donc
moi je me suis j'ai réfléchi j'ai fait
des choses que ce soit des sujets qui
soit proche de la vie quotidienne des
gens que les gens s'y retrouvent quoi
vous avez imaginé un moment au moment de
cette conception que un demi siècle plus
tard ses oeuvres strella auraient leur
histoire aurait vu plusieurs générations
va maintenant juste quand on est jeune
moi j'étais jeune à l'époque mais
maintenant qu'on s'imaginait pas
l'avenir c'est maintenant que je me
rends compte à quel point qui a eu un
impact que les gens sur la peau prier
merci beaucoup encore gérard amon nous
avons reçu ici dans votre atelier
parisien
merci à vaduz emploi
[Musique]
ça fait huit ans que j'habite ça donc
il ya tout aux alentours et la bd belle
quoi dans chaque quartier il ya des
petits des mini centres commerciaux donc
en fait il ya une boulangerie une
pharmacie un peu dans chaque quartier
donc c'est assez agréable pour tous n'y
a pas besoin de faire des kilomètres
pour avoir l'essentiel est surtout là
tanguay l'idée ça c'est sûr que ici aux
côtés tant qu'il est on est on est bien
en fait j'habite ici ça fait huit ans
que je suis ici moi il la famille et on
est bien on est tranquille il ya des
parcs pour les enfants il y a
il ya le bois de maurepas fin oui c'est
on à la ville est un peu la campagne en
même temps nous venons d'entendre les
mauraciennes ne mord pas bien nous
parler de leur commune ce qu'ils en
pensaient nous allons maintenant
rencontrer le maire de maurepas à
grégory gaultier bonjour bonjour nous
sommes venus ici dans votre commune pour
vous écouter un petit peu nous parler de
vos anecdotes de jeunesse parce que sa
ville de maurepas vous la connaissez
bien vous êtes élu depuis à 2014 mais
vous avez grandi ici nés en 92 vous
n'avez jamais quitté maurepas c'est vrai
j'ai grandi à maurepas j'évite toujours
depuis 1982 j'habite d'ailleurs sur le
mile qui est juste derrière nous et
c'est vrai que cette ville elle est
riche d'un des docks dans ma vie avec
mes amis d'ailleurs ici un lieu
emblématique c'est la côte d'or le
centre ville
on est au milieu du centre-ville la
mairie est juste à côté est exactement
où j'ai appris à faire du vélo et du
roller pas loin là sur la place riboud
il y avait une oeuvre d'art qui
s'appelait les landes gérard amon
maintenant qui a été déplacé au
rond-point de seuil de coignières ou
avec deux amis on s'amusait l'hiver à
faire des glissades à jouer dans la
neige et sur le verglas
donc voilà différentes anecdotes
derrière vous il y avait le magasin
peugeot
il y avait une tirette toujours ma
petite pièce pour les chercher des
pétards des claques doigt ou d'ailleurs
je m'amuse avec les passants à leur
faire peur peut donc voilà plein de
petites anecdotes comme ça qu'ils ont
construit l'homme que je suis
aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que cette ville de maurepas
vous y avait une attention vous y prêter
une attention particulière j'imagine
parce qu'on l'envoie le centre-ville en
réaménagement mais lorsqu'il a fallu
réaménager vous avez pensé à tous ces
moments là aussi dans cette commune pour
pas de dénaturer la ville peut-être oui
c'est vrai aussi et voilà il ya une
particularité parce que du fait que je
suis né à maurepas que j'ai toujours
vécu à maurepas donc j'ai une relation
qui est assez particulière c'est une
ville de coeur
au delà même de la politique c'est à
dire quand les habitants aussi viennent
me voir quand je communique avec eux
quand j'ai changé avec eux je sais de
quoi je parle et je sais de quoi mais
les habitants me parle la rue lassante
parce que je connais par coeur la vie de
maurepas et donc c'est avec d'autant
plus de passion et de coeur que j'agis
au quotidien et donc c'est vrai que pour
moi la rénovation du centre-ville
quelque part c'est un renouveau c'est
d'essayer d'imiter un peu l'esprit de
jacques riboud de l'époque qui était le
promoteur de la ville de maurepas donc
voilà une richesse qui aujourd'hui fait
que maurepas est une ville que l'on aime
merci hugo rigueur et astier version
bientôt refermée ce numéro de bienvenue
en yvelines auparavant connaissez vous
l'histoire du blason de maurepas c'est
nicolas qui rit le vide qui nous
l'expliquent
c'est à l'une des plus puissantes
familles de la noblesse française que la
ville de maurepas doit son blason et ses
couleurs
la famille defilippo a fourni notamment
de nombreux ministres et secrétaires
d'état la royauté
parmi eux le compte de maurepas
jean-frédéric phélippeau cet homme né à
versailles a servi successivement louis
15 et louis saez
il fut en charge notamment de la marine
pendant 26 ans les couleurs de la
famille philippot deviendront
officiellement celle de maurepas dans
les années 70 quelques évolutions
esthétiques ne changeront pas ses
caractéristiques essentielles et d'azur
semer de cartes feuille d'or offrant
canton d'hermine fin de ce premier
numéro de bienvenue en yvelines préparé
avec l'aide de nicolas kirillovitch
merci également à la ville de maurepas
pour nous avoir aidé à construire ce
numéro on se quitte avec quelques images
de patrick jacques de dixmude
à très bientôt
[Musique]
où